in the lobby of Ramsey siliceous
solutions yeah that megan has dropped by
I'm Megan how are you good Dave how are
you better than I deserve so I
understand you've got a question yes I
do so about a year and a half ago my
husband and I were right here and we did
our debt-free scream since that time
however I have had myself I've had a
really hard time letting go a little bit
and spending money now that we are not
in ghazal mode and I didn't know if you
had any suggestions as to how I could
handle that hmm give me an example I
just don't know if we're doing enough I
don't know for saving enough for
retirement what are you not what are you
not what do you spend money on and it
feels weird if you did or something you
almost spent money on but you couldn't
well we're so we're so icky n-- to the
budget that we're like i don't know can
we do that we don't mean example let's
see I'm a home improvements okay like
what new hardwood floors that are going
to be really expensive we want to do it
with the money to do it it's hard to let
go of that okay how much are they I
would think probably close to ten
thousand maybe eight to ten thousand
what's your household income about 120
it varies every year because I am on a
variable income you've already got the
money saved for it correct there's
something you had a goal to do yes but
we also are saving for cars with the
same money correct we're just putting
everything into our into our savings
fund so when I look at that money I
think that's really for our cars I don't
know how much of that we can really
spend because we're really trying to
save for cars that's different than I
can't turn loose of the money that's I'm
confused on which thing to buy okay I
don't care which one you buy how old are
your cars we're praying they don't go at
the same time mine is about eight years
old my husband's is about five I go
through them very quickly so we're
looking at something very inexpensive
for myself mm-hmm all right well I think
you just need to lay out a game plan say
all right we're gonna do all three of
these things we're going to buy two cars
and some hardwoods
alright okay and we've got ten $10,000
towards that or how much money have you
got towards that goal well everything is
just lumped together I know not counting
your emergency fund but how much above
the emergency fund I probably thirty
thousand okay cool and so the hardwoods
are eight or ten but he goes have been
on the cars probably for myself probably
no more than fifteen thousand I have
from listening to you I know that we
should not buy new that's twenty five
nothing else so probably about fifteen
thousand for myself maybe about twenty
for my husband so it's about thirty five
thousand in cars and other ten needy and
hardwoods okay and so that's 45 and you
got thirty so when we have them the
other fifteen and which one is going to
wait which one of the three just
prioritize them one two three
which car which hard what car car
hardwoods put them in some order start
doing one of them now okay with the
money that's there or two of them now
with the money that's there and so he's
gonna get the first car probably me
because I go through them so quickly and
I am in the car a lot for work
you got the mind do those two things all
right well your first are you before the
hardwoods probably I really want those
hardwoods Dave I know we argue before
the heart is a car more important than
the hardwoods I don't care the car
should last some time I'm gonna drive it
until she dies so she so she should some
still have some time left and you're the
car and the hardwoods are both in front
of his car
correct okay didn't do the hardwoods in
the car you got the money to do those
two things and start saving towards his
car okay you know and anything wrong
it's just so hard to spend it all you
gotta do that well but I mean it's
already spent in your mind you're going
to do it mm-hmm
you have to do the car you're gonna do
the hardwoods it made you smile when you
were talking about them you've got the
money you've saved the money you've
worked hard that's why you you live like
no one else so later you can live like
no one else and none of these purchases
are out of line based on a ratio to your
income nothing here was crazy you didn't
tell you're gonna spend $200,000 on a
car making 100 grand you know or
something like that you're just moving
up in cars and you're buying decent
vehicles and so I I would immediately
get the contract get three contractor
bids on the hardwoods and I start
shopping for a car
you have the money well it feels
frivolous to me to buy say hardwoods and
not something that's gonna be more
lasting like a car but maybe we should
do retirement first like I feel like
maybe we should really be jamming our
retirement are you putting 15% of your
income in direct we're doing about 20 to
25 percent 15 percent all you're
supposed to be doing but my husband
didn't invest at all prior to our
including 15 percent okay good enough
and you're supposed to be paying off
your house we did that if house has
already paid off
yeah oh okay there no no no then you
would be at 20 or whatever yeah so
you're fine at 22 you're fine you're
doing fine okay you say it's your age if
you save 22 percent of your income
that's $25,000 a year for the next many
many many years you're gonna be so rich
it's gonna be unbelievable in the
hardwoods aren't gonna keep you from
doing that so you're supposed to balance
and do some giving some saving and some
enjoyment of money and really the only
thing on this list that's enjoyment a
little bit of the car is enjoyment and
the hardwoods so enjoy it okay that's
what you want to do with it that's why
you work yeah do it write the checks
thanks Dave thanks for stopping by
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you